ouais je suis gâté comme j'ai dit dans
le reportage qui va piquer passé sur ces
8 j'ai pas été un enfant gâté mais
j'étais un adulte a vécu des épreuves
terribles aussi moche ça fait partie du
jeu ça tu sais ces choses là te donne
encore plus justement aujourd'hui quand
je repense aux douleurs extrêmes que
j'ai eu la perte de mon fils le récent
match tout seul c'est en 90 je confie
sébastien va mourir à 19 ans dans un
accident de moto et tu as dit que c'est
arrivé à plat la durance total tadieu
alors en temps de l'afrique la pire
phrase du monde pour toi est ce que vous
voulez venir reconnaître le corps de
votre fils à la morgue
ça c'est un truc c'est la pire phrase
que tu peux entendre dans ta vie c'est
sûr ça sera la pire phase il peut me
dire n'importe quoi comme insulte
aujourd'hui ça sera jamais aussi violent
que ça patrick moi j'ai laissé reposer
parce que mes copains que la femme non
plus - tafer pour revenir à l'antenne
est ce que tu es revenu tout de suite à
l'antenne après non mais je suis monté
sur scène tout de suite le soir parce
que c'est une question de survie
et moi j'ai eu une chance extraordinaire
j'avais un public qui me donner de
l'amour à qui je devais de l'amour mais
je pense à tous ces gens qui perdent
quelqu'un et qui ont personne à côté
parce qu'il faut quand il faut pas
s'écrouler par terre au contraire faut
rester faut rester debout
moi ma devise c'est ça c'est resté
debout quoi qu'il en soit ce qui s'est
passé à la télé c'est très très violents
ce qu'ils m'ont fait mais je vais rester
debout je veux pas finir à quatre pattes
jamais jamais et je resterai et je
resterai debout jusqu'au bout et toutes
ces douleurs là j'ai perdu
tu sais mon téléphone tout mes favoris
mon père ma mère ou rigides kg dont tu
parlais mes meilleures amies tout ça ça
dégage et on tient sinon et puis ça te
donne encore plus de force pour donner
de l'amour aux autres il ya une chose
que les magnifiques occuper des autres
en ont besoin une chose qui était
magnifique dans ce malheur en partance
et bastien tu as laissé quelqu'un ça sa
maman est enceinte lors de l'accident
mais cinq mois plus tard et une étape
petite fille marie on l'a vu tenir ses
mains da c'est mon fils fait traîner les
choses très belles sur moi elle a dit
une chose très très belle
quand je dis que je veux pas être son
père de remplacement elle m'a dit c'est
mon repère s'est trouvé ça très alors
ben regarde mon regarde parce que elle
t'a laissé un petit message d'espoir non
artois marie sissi map le gabon passe
alors aujourd'hui j'avais envie de te
faire une petit
surprise parce que comme tu le sais dans
deux jours c'est l'anniversaire de papa
et malheureusement s'il était encore
parmi nous aujourd'hui il aurait eu 50
ans alors tu sais que j'ai eu besoin
d'extérioriser tout ça de créer de
composer j'ai fait un morceau sur lui
jusque là jamais là mais longtemps
en attendant je t'embrasse très très
fort je t'aime très fort et j'en profite
aussi pour embrasser manman je vous aime
de tout mon coeur j'avais elle m'avait
fait entendre le texte n'avait pas vu
les images là c'est un lien c'est un
lien extraordinaire parce que quand on
se croise mais ça arrive dans tellement
d'autres familles c'est un lien
extraordinaire qui fait que tu es obligé
de vivre avec les absents voilà c'est
comme ça c'est la vie c'est est ce que
j'essaie de lui de lui inculquer à elle
et qu'on essaie d'inculquer partout
autour de nous c'est ça c'est cette
bienveillance et ce alors on s'est
tellement moquer de moi tu sais au plus
tôt c'est que de l'amour tu sais eh ben
ouais moi pour moi c'est la seule
solution
surtout dans les conditions dans
lesquelles on joue aujourd'hui j'ai fait
récemment j'ai fait des trucs chez les
youtuber tu sais un qg cul sec ça
rétorque son lectorat son pêne
bienveillance ils sont plein de
gentillesse et ben ça rassure de voir
des mondes de 25 balles et 26 balles et
qui sont pas dans l'agressivité qui sont
pas dans le voit qu'ils sont je vais pas
dire normand normaux mais ça il ya une
majorité dans notre pays puisque tu veux
parler de l'actualité temps d'en parler
comme ça il ya plein de gens qui sont
solidaires plein de gens qui ont des
drames est bien pire que les miens parce
que moi
bon c'est mon fils ici tu es de bonne
heure quelque part sans jeu de mots
parce que c'est très matin mais il s'est
tué en roulant trop vite et en se
faisant plaisir mais j'ai croisé
tellement de gens qui ont eu des des
mômes qui chope des leucémies à 10 ans
que je veux dire c'est c'est abominable
donc il faut pas se plaindre faut faire
avec nos valeurs